i want to ask you quickly uh i don't
know this is just a part of your life as
everyone knows the tabloids just
people are fascinated by you and your
life they just always want to write
about you they seem to write all kinds
of things and then you think i'll read
them and i think i don't think that has
any basis in reality but i thought
you're here is it okay if i ask you set
the record straight let's talk about it
it says what they've been reporting a
lot you're adopting a baby
where is this coming from
it's coming from i think it was the star
i have no idea doesn't we don't do that
kind of research we can no yes
we can't afford it apparently
adopting a child from mexico right and
any truth to that
nope okay uh
i read an article they said on a on
movie sets people must stay it's a rule
you must stay 20 feet away from jennifer
aniston and i thought okay i know her
pretty well one of the friendliest
people i've met that can't be true where
do they come up with this i don't know
they have to i don't know but that was
that was a funny one wasn't it they
can't look me in the eye or look that's
hard if you're acting with somebody
yes i've noticed in a lot of scenes in
your movies no one's looking at you
that's wrong no i think i just need to
go out more i don't go out enough
because so then they just create the
stuff well the other thing too is i
noticed years ago when i worked on the
old late night show i ran into a page
once who looked me and said i'm so sorry
i looked at you and i said what are you
talking about and they said well there's
a rule that we're not supposed to look
you in the eye
i said what are you talking about i'm
the most emotionally needy person they
talk to me yeah danny why isn't it i
thought they were all mad at me and some
other page had just made it up you know
don't look at him he's crazy i guess or
something oh that's so mean i probably
did slap him around
you recently said you hated the rachel
haircut which i think we actually have a
photo of just for old times
but again i don't think that's quite
what you said i didn't hate it there
obviously i was pretty confident about
that
check out this hair
that's the way superman stands that is
isn't it
yeah no that and that hairdo lasted
about a total i think of seven months
right and it has le has had legs of 15
years yeah it had such a cultural impact
yeah i guess i don't i didn't hate it it
was just you you know and you're
becoming you must get that all the time
like being all better haircut
yes this is called the conan
kids all every kid wants this haircut uh
ah that's not funny um
uh i wanna talk about the movie just go
with it yeah i was telling adam sandler
uh that i i saw this film and i really
enjoyed it and what i really one of the
things i enjoyed the most is you two
have a great natural chemistry you seem
like you're very good friends and you're
really making each other laugh that was
the that's the sense you get when you
watch this it's true we would we would
actually uh have so much we just had so
much fun together and it was on digital
so our takes would go for 45 i mean a
long time because and we would just be
cracking each other up yeah you can tell
there's real honest moments in there and
i guess you've become friends because is
he not taking you to the super bowl he's
taking me to the super bowl adam's
taking you this year have you been to a
super bowl i have never been to the
super bowl yeah thank god i'm excited
i'm going with adam who who knows a
thing or two about sports do you not i'm
not necessarily
totally yeah do you know anything about
this game that's coming up are you at
all interested in football well i i have
i'm thankful that i now know that it's
it's it's not the cowboys are not going
even though it's in dallas which was
confusing
[Laughter]
no so you've established that the
cowboys aren't playing chicks chicks
talking sports yeah so good no um and
yeah i watched uh about six hours of
football last weekend you know to get
yourself caught up oh really you just
you're like oh they're throwing that
pigskin around
oh this isn't about a bat okay
no so no i'm not going i'm not that
silly but but you actually find yourself
getting excited you can't help yourself
and i get what what the what the the
whole thing is i found i was by myself
and cheering and going or going like oh
no no don't don't goddamn so yeah i'm
excited to go i hope i just really make
a full of myself honestly right right
well there's an intensity there i got to
go to super bowl a couple years ago i
went a few years ago and i just was
stunned by
everyone it just feels like you know 100
million people or something are watching
worldwide and so there's an intensity to
it and the fans are so crazy and you
drink a lot and it's really great it's
fun that sounds a little terrifying yeah
i took my shirt off and ran around did
not okay i did not no one wanted that uh